ich muss jetzt wirklich aufpassen was
ich sage so ich kann erst mal so sagen
es gibt schon ein paar deutsche youtube
in die ich ganz attraktiv finde leute
was glaubt willkommen beim neuen video
ja ich hab euch auf ins tagen befragt
ich brauche mal wieder die richtig
krachen fragen von euch die ich
beantworten kann damit sein
unterhaltsames video wird ihr habt mir
heftig viele fragen geschickt
darf ich im verbund rausgesucht ins
übrigens so wenn ihr auch das nächste
mal dabei sein wollen und mir fragen
stellen wollen könnt ihr mir gerne
verfolgen ja ich hab mal gesagt stellt
mir ganz normale fragen zum 90 prozent
der fragen war dann so was wie mit
wieviel jahren hast das erstmal wie lang
ist ein
hattest du schon mal was mit einer
jährigen mit ok das war jetzt vielleicht
etwas übertrieben aber ich habe nur
gedacht was ist los mit euch also habt
ihr euch alle jedenfalls genommen in der
schule oder sonst wo die kommt ihr auf
solche fragen halten war wirklich es ist
solche komischen sachen waren dabei da
dachte ich bei mir egal ich will gar
nicht eingeladen bevor wir anfangen
wollte ich euch aber noch aussagen zu
erwartenden erstatten hab dann gedacht
dieses teil die eigentlich ganz cool aus
aber irgendwie auch nicht als ich habe
das jetzt einfach angezogen schreibt man
die kommentare oder wir machen das
einfach wieder so wenn ihr findet das
kann man tragen lassen doch nach oben da
wenn ihr findet man kann es nicht tragen
lassen noch nach unten da weil ich finde
es eigentlich ganz cool aber so dieses
hier net siege so was halt hier noch
drüber geht sie gegen ein bisschen
depressiv aus oder so finde ich jetzt
gerade gut also meinetwegen auch erst
während des videos wenns euch dann halt
so mehr gefällt mit der zeit lassen nach
oben da wenn nicht doch unten wirklich
knallhart sein
wir fangen jetzt sofort an mit der
ersten frage und die kommt von keine
ahnung ich muss kurz auf mein handy
gruppen und zwar leute haltet euch fest
die erste frage bekommst du nackt bilder
von deinen fan ich will jetzt gar nicht
sagen dass ich täglich vor durchweg
bilder bekomme allerdings kommt das
manchmal wirklich so plötzlich mein
rechnet da 0 mit zac bild sowie chat vor
allem bei snapshot heißt übrigens so
könnte mir auch gerne folgen
und ich nehme jetzt wirklich gar kein
doktor im mund und fünf landeten die
premiere findet das baby also leute an
euch daraus ihr braucht mir keine
nacktbilder schicken
ich fahre da nicht so darauf ab so ist
nicht so mein ding
aber bitte erst dann wenn ihr auf 18
seiten ein spaß wird auch mit so was ich
will dass
und bitte lasst uns jetzt finde ich
nicht gut klingt voll ernst geblieben
wir machen weiter mitnichten so hier
schon wieder ich sehe gerade schon
wieder so eine fahrt auf instagram hast
du ein sexspielzeug was meint frage ich
grundsätzlich erstmal aus dem weg wir
machen weiter mit der nächsten frage und
zwar kann ich dich auf einen drink
einladen
du kannst dich auch gerne auf 10 grings
einladen wenn du bezahlst kannst du mich
auf locker zu machen das war jetzt eine
sehr kurze frage mit einer sehr kurze
antwort deswegen machen wir weiter
warum traust du dich nicht deinen bauch
vor der kamera zu zeigen hey ich hab
meinen bauch schon locker dreimal
gezeigt oder so hier zufrieden das war
jetzt locker dein ziel also mit der
frage wollte zu erreichen dass ich
meinen bauch zeige wetten immer diese
notgeilen kommen wir zur nächsten frage
und zwar fragt irgendwo einem alley
dachtest du jemals in deinem leben schon
als ein typ vorbeilief der sieht so heiß
aus nein obwohl will
moment mal alter bis zu heiß wer bist du
ich bin mir nicht mehr doch ist mir
anscheinend schon passiert zu kommen
doch schon zur nächsten frage die ich
wirklich schon sehr oft gelesen habe und
zwar fragt irgendeine welche youtube
drin würdest du mal gerne näher
kennenlernen beziehungsweise welche
youtube endest du heißt das habe ich
auch ganz auf gelesen so ich muss jetzt
wirklich aufpassen was ich sage so ich
kann erst mal so sagen so es gibt schon
ein paar deutsche youtube in die ich
ganz attraktiv finde also um ehrlich zu
sein diese katja glaser vallata witze
oder wieder heißt ist an sich so klar
viel kunst bzw 4 künstlich aber an sich
ist die schon ganz heiß ich schüler ist
aber es gibt natürlich auch noch sehr
viele andere heiße mädchen die noch
heißer sind was die deutsche youtube
szene angeht finde ich die schon okay
also ist ganz heiß da gebe es auch
attraktiv für ihn da wird es auch
attraktiv aber das war es eigentlich
auch schon also das sind 30 finde ich
ganz süß aber ich kann da noch eine
person die es viel süßes kommen wir auch
schon zur nächsten frage und zwar
wurdest du in der schule mal von youtube
gemobbt oder ähnliches also ganz ehrlich
ich hab ja letztens mal so ein video
gemacht da habe ich euch mein erster
youtube video gezeigt bzw irgendwie eins
der ersten und da kann man auch schon
direkt da als resultat daraus ziehen
er wurde mal wegen seiner youtube-videos
gemobbt weil die einfach scheiße und
peinlich waren also heute werde ich
deswegen natürlich nicht weg überhaupt
ich mein so es gibt da welche die fans
wirklich richtig cool es gibt welche die
fans ganz okay es gibt auch viele die
frage sich warum verdienter spaß die
damit sogar geld lockt ja aber früher so
ich erinnere mich so an die achte klasse
zurück da gab es auch schon ein paar die
konnten mich glaube ich aufgrund dieser
videos nicht mehr ganz so ernst nehmen
so versteht ihr das war jetzt kein
morgen oder so aber so halt und leute
kommen wir zur letzten frage die auch
wirklich komplett die heutige lage
meiner instagram fragensteller darstellt
oder widerspiegelt und so fragte hast du
schon mal dran gedacht ein porno zu
drehen so nein habe ich eigentlich noch
nicht so ich denke immer so wenn man
eine maske auf hat ist das kein thema
aber sonst auf keinen fall heute mehr
budget auch gar nicht loswerden ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen wie gesagt
daumen nach oben oder nach unten für
dieses t shirt die snapshot instagram
als eingewendet könnt ihr mir gerne
folgen wenn ihr auch mal bei den
nächsten fragen dabei sein wollte
unbedingt weiter mit meinem letzten
check das abo nicht vergessen ob ich
dazu verpassen wir sehen uns dann am
morgen eventuell schon wieder ein genau
werden wir sehen vertreten